I am now going to bring out the senior
senator from the great state of
Minnesota and a 2020 Democratic
presidential candidate please welcome
Amy Klobuchar
[Applause]
[Music]
so breakfast
[Applause]
thanks for having me oh thank you
okay so Trump was in Minnesota that's
right he says he can win it that is the
state that they are wrong well he that's
the one they think they can flip well
that is not gonna happen as long as I'm
leaving the ticket and one of the
reasons that I think we need to bring
more people in is because we've got to
win not just Minnesota which was close
last time in his race but then I came
storming back in 2018 and won every
Republican congressional district and
what we need to do is to extend that out
to Wisconsin and Michigan and
Pennsylvania
I just went to all of those states met
with carpenters met with dock workers
people who had made promises - that have
been left behind by President Trump well
and so what I want to do is build a blue
wall around those states well I heard
that term last time but didn't work I'm
gonna make him pay for it
I think you probably could I hope you
can do you think the Democrats though
are too into identity politics I mean a
lot of people in the middle of the
country which you represent so well they
they see that D next to someone's name
and it's it's just something they can't
get behind why is that why is that D so
toxic well first of all it's not toxic
to everyone and we have a real fired up
base right now and that is going to be
so important people who have felt hurt
by this guy hurt by his rhetoric wake up
in the morning seeing him go after their
entire city and calling it rat infested
those things have happened but when you
get to the middle of the country his
trade war has hurt a bunch of our
farmers they've got soybeans mounting up
in bins his rhetoric is not what people
want to have their kids listen to and
they have to turn down the TV every
single time he goes on TV I remember the
days when if you didn't agree with the
President or maybe you didn't even vote
for them you'd be proud to say this is
my nation and this is my leader that's
not true with this president when you
look at what he has done so to me this
is about economics and not standing up
like I would and taking on the
pharmaceutical industry and not doing
anything when it comes to training
people and making sure they're ready for
the jobs of tomorrow and immigration
reform it's about all those things but
it's also about values we believe in
America and he has put patriotism behind
his own interests that's what those
calls were to the head of Ukraine and
the cult to the president of China when
he's looking for dirt on an opponent
he's putting his own political interests
his own partisan interests his own
business interests in front of America
and that's why I see a different kind of
election I see a fired up Democratic
base and with someone like me leading
the ticket where you can bring in
independence and you can bring in
moderate Republicans and you can win big
not just win and then you can govern in
a different way because this guy has
divided people in
that we have not seen in this country so
what do you see is your path to the
nomination
well my path first of all starts with
this show because they say I haven't had
a viral moment so going on it's good
Howard Stern out here and really
starting a fire
we need a viral moment tell me now what
could go wrong you know right no
seriously I'm that's what these debates
have been and I have been on a steady
course I think Americans don't want the
loudest voice in the room anymore they
got that in the White House I think they
want someone that is tired of the noise
and nonsense and want to get things done
right I don't yeah I I don't know if
those moments are so great I mean Kamala
Harris had moments and she's not doing
too good
you know you're right moments don't make
yeah and I think that moments work when
there actually happened that people
don't manufacture them right for me in
the Cavanaugh hearing I didn't exactly
predict that the nominee was going to
ask me if I blacked out but I had a
moment where I had to respond in that
moment right I remember that yes and I
see likes beer you like beer just
actually and I showed some grace under
pressure and I think that's really
important in a president so for me it is
of course going to those states I don't
have as much money as a number of my
opponents but I have enough money to win
we're doing this the right way the
grassroots way in building up
endorsements and support and that's how
you win an election in America yeah I
mean obviously obviously this is a fight
between two wings of the party which is
almost every election there is a center
in the Democrat a center left weighing
your plenti liberal you're plenty
progressive and then there's a far left
which I think would be represented by
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren okay
yeah okay we all like them too I'm they
to left is Elizabeth too far away we get
elected in a general election I want to
win big and if someone is looking to
kick 149 million Americans off their
current health insurance in four years
then I'm not your candidate if you want
to use a bunch of hard-working people's
money to send rich people's kids to
college for free then I'm not your
candidate and just because people say
ideas are bold doesn't mean they're bold
they may be bad
and so my bold ideas are this make it
easier for kids to afford to go to
college but don't forget that there are
many paths to success and that right now
we have a huge need in our country for
jobs that require one in two-year
degrees and we should not leave those
people behind remembering that we need
to take on farmer prices public option
take on climate change in a big way
something that this president has just
gone backwards on work with the rest of
the world not leave our allies behind
don't coddle dictators and when I was
listening to the panel before I was not
in Washington but I was not for the Iraq
war but I would never leave those Kurds
for left for slaughter like this guy has
done that is not what America does right
that's not what you do you honor your
commitment you keep you make your your
promises and your threats and you keep
them and this is the whole world is
watching right now so I think to get
back to the center-left argument I think
you're probably more in the again center
left not far left and that's gonna come
down to one candidate from each now
right now it's Joe Biden who was the
leader of the sent the center-left part
one applaud I've always said I like Joe
he'd never mocked my favorite but if
he's the guy to beat Trump I was like
let's not kill him because if he's the
one but I must say my confidence that he
can beat Trump is waning he looks like a
depreciating stock to me
and I've always said the Olsens as we're
talking about aids with Howard wait I've
always fought against ageism because
it's a judgmental thing that you know
very few can do that by very few other
things in America anymore it's a
case-by-case basis elizabeth warren is
70 she looks 50 in acts 20 she she took
selfies with 4000 people I don't even
know if I trust someone who wants to be
President that much Joe I don't know and
Bernie you know just had a heart attack
I I think that you know I'm not trying
to get Joe out but the we do need
someone in the center who say younger
and female are you know so my case is
this yeah I have won every single race
every single time all the way back to
elementary school where I have guys
always say they've won everything so
when my slogan I discarded was all the
way with Amy Kay
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and I've done what was the upshot what
happened by going not just where it's
comfortable but where it's uncomfortable
right by bringing people with me by
reaching out to people by unifying them
and seeing that common ground and that's
how I've gotten things done in
Washington I think you could be the Dark
Horse because you know it is gonna come
down to that battle and maybe they were
at loggerheads this has happened at
conventions before and they have to find
somebody who's a compromise and you know
you're a woman let's face it when you're
but that's just important in today's
politics if you're a white man a lot of
women were one hard racist Laura Kelly
new governor of Kansas right right and
you saw that but I'm saying it's a lot
easier to be on the center side of
things as Obama was if you are not a
white man if you're a white straight man
it's like ah you know then you're
suspect a bit but a wouldn't make it
clear and I am excited to be one of
several women in this race which is just
unheard of in our politics but I'm not
just running on that no I know
absolutely right and that can go we can
get to that and then you lose a lot of
people right I remember being up in
northern Minnesota with our steel
workers and they would always I finally
would say you know what I'm not running
as a woman I'm running on my record and
if I would just run as a woman I
wouldn't win because they would be like
this I said because half the voters are
men and they go ideas running on your
merit running on turning ideas into
action and having people's back instead
of just going to the extremes all the
time in our politics we have that right
now and I just see a better future for
our country I think your moment is to
come all right Thank You senator Roberts
sure everybody
you